San Francisco I'll be back Friday
December 8th and Saturday December 9th
at Cobbs Comedy Club it's the last stop
of the live and Alive tour for 2023 get
your tickets at
ryanr the honey do with Brian
[Music]
[Applause]
sichler welcome back to the Honeydew
y'all we're over here doing the night
pants Studios I am Ryan sichler Ryan
kichler.com and Ryan sichler on all your
social media I'm going to start this
episode like I start every episode thank
you thank you for supporting the show
watching listening wherever you get it
whether you're new here or whether
you've been here thank you so much make
sure you're subscribed it is a free way
to help the show get out there and be
suggested and and get those downloads
and everything up all right if you got
to have more then you got to have the
patreon listen to me it's called the
Honeydew with y'all and it's this show
with y'all and y'all have the wildest
stories we have hundreds of episodes
it's available right now and it is worth
every single penny it's five bucks all
right it's a cup of coffee and you're
getting a hundreds hundreds of episodes
excuse me and if you're also looking for
a new podcast to listen to you got to
listen to my old podcast to crab Feast
it's it's been gone for five years and
the library did over a million downloads
this year so thank you very much for
that everybody that feaster nation is
alive and well and uh come see me on the
road the last dates for this year are
cobs December 8th and 9th all right more
to come next year all tickets at Ryan
sickler docomo what we're doing over
here I always say we're highlighting the
low lights and that these are the
stories behind the storytellers I'm very
excited to have this guest on first time
here on the de ladies and Gentlemen
please welcome Rob rigle welcome to the
honey thanks for having
me thank you for being here Rob rle it's
a pleasure thank you uh before we get
into whatever we're going to talk about
today please plug promote everything and
anything you would like oh well uh uh
I'm uh I'm relaunching uh a podcast uh
that we uh Sarah Tiana great comedian
she's been on the honey her mom's a big
fan yeah good good uh she's amazing and
uh we used to do this podcast called
wles Picks It was kind of based on the
Fox comedy bit I used to do before for
the pregame mhm uh called wles picks as
well um and uh but we changed the format
up uh we we we stopped doing it about
three years ago uh right when covid hit
basically I uh covid
hit I was going through I just started
going through a divorce and and Sarah
was having a baby so it you know was
just the perfect storm so we were like
you know what let's just call it so we
did and then uh and now uh three years
later uh I'm bringing bringing it back
and so hopefully uh uh people enjoy it
I'm doing it with Darren leader good
friend uh incredible musician and we uh
We've interjected interviews into it so
we'll be doing some celebrity interviews
and and uh and interesting people
interviews not just celebrities but just
people that I think have something
interesting to say and people need to
hear it so it'll be fun it'll be a lot
of fun so that's coming out wles piic
wherever you get Podcast all right
anything else social media that's it I
mean you
rob by the way do you have Rob rigle or
you have to have a one or I have Rob rle
on most of it I think I have Rob rle
most there's always one out there like I
think there's one Facebook one has to be
something else cuz some other Ryan
sickler think I got I think I got to
wles piic or I got to and wles pick by
the way will have all of this so there's
wles picks.com there's wles piix on
Insta on all this stuff so you can find
wles picks or Rob rle all right anywhere
um so I I really know nothing about you
growing up I know about about you just
from Comedy and I just watched your
roast again the other day and um but
tell me about yourself where are you
from originally and where did you grow
up what was that like for you uh I grew
up in the midwest uh I had a great great
childhood know no complaints what state
are you from uh Kansas oh wow Overland
Park Kansas is Kansas considered Midwest
it is it's not like the southwest Little
no God no Oklahoma New Mexico Arizona
that's the southwest Oklahoma see I
would go yeah I guess that's Southwest
and Texas right above Texas all
Southwest so I'm Kansas uh one of the
rectangle States goes Kansas uh well
Oklahoma but they have a panh handle so
it's a weird Sil state but then Kansas
Nebraska South Dakota North Dakota
Canada so we're in that square block
that rectangle block um yeah no we're
you can't get more center of the country
Kansas um but I grew up in O Park Kansas
which is a suburb of of Kansas City okay
yeah so great childhood great great
childhood and and uh um and and why
Kansas your parents like your family
from my family from there yeah my
parents were both from there I was born
in Louisville Kentucky uh because my dad
was he was selling Insurance there um
and then he got U he finally got the
transfer he kept putting in for was to
get back to Kansas City because that's
where everybody's family was from my mom
and my dad so and how many siblings uh
one sister one sister and Mom and Dad
what's dad do they're Farmers oh I was
going to ask you really are far so you
grew up on a farm uh I didn't grow up on
a farm the farm belonged to my
grandparents so uh my I worked on the
farm you did yeah that was my summer job
was always working on the farm U but it
was a good job because my my grandfather
you know he paid well and he paid cash
did he pay well you you didn't just have
to do it yeah no no oh hell yeah okay so
you're employed yeah I was but tell us
what you're doing cuz this is worth
money I'm imagining it's not easy work
it was weird it was you at the time uh
this would have been in the 80s so I was
you know 12 Middle School yeah Middle
School um uh all the way through high
school and uh uh so when the combine
goes through the bean fields or the corn
fields it's got these forks and it it
gathers all the stuff in but in the rows
if there A lot of times there's milkweed
and shatter cane and all these different
types of things that are growing that
can clog up the gears so my job was to
go out into these fields and just walk
these rows of being beans or corn with a
machete and cut out the milked and the
and the shatter cane out of the out of
the Rose so they didn't clog up the
gears on the
combine um I remember milkweed I'm from
Maryland that [__] was thick that wasn't
that wasn't an easy little fine to and
you had to cut it off at the roots you
could just cut it off top bend over and
and smack that thing down by and rip it
out by its roots and and of course you
know at the time you know I was anywhere
from 10 to 18 right so you had to back
for I had I had a machete you know but I
turned it into like I'm out there doing
Samurai warrior [__] you know like I'm
not focused on the work you know I'm I'm
cutting it three different ways doing
Zoro doing you
know Lord
Vader um so you know I'm sure my grandpa
be like wait you only did this one acre
right this is all you did yeah and so
you know I'd go out they my grand my
grandfather would drop me off with my
machete and a and a thermos and I'd go
out and just start working by yourself
by myself and wa let's talk about this
day because now there's no airpods
there's no Spotify in my fingers so are
you headphones or you nothing just tying
a shirt around your head and going going
me and my thoughts and and lonely and
you know um you know the good thing was
at that age I didn't have many heavy
thoughts you know I wasn't overly
concerned with anything no but you're
out there Jedi and Samurai and
everything else just being creative in
this field of like and the biggest thing
for me was you know you you'd have you
know he drop you off at a 40 acre plot
or whatever ask that's big as [__] D
your hand walking a 4 AC yeah and and
you work your way down one row and like
to me like the real satisfaction is when
I got to the end of the row and turn
around and come back the other row you
know I was like ah it's like swimming
laps like I was just kept going I kept
going and the Sun and the Heat and you
know but when you're young you just
don't know one you don't know any better
two it is what it is and you just do it
uh and then they would come either my
grandmother or my grandfather would come
back out at noon and uh honk the horn
and so I knew oh and that was lunch
lunch yeah so I'd run over and we' sit
there and I'd eat and I was stalled
dragg it out all of a sudden I'm a
conversationalist you know I say
anything to PR and eventually was like
all right time to go back to work I was
like oh for the love of God so I'd go
back and then they'd come back in the
evening and hwk the horn I'd go back
what' he pay do you remember at the time
it was good it was cash I remember days
pay or was it hourly like how'd he pay
days pay yeah days pay and uh because
you know the amount of work some days
I'd be motivated and go out there and
you know make a dent and some days I'd
be [__] around you know not getting
anything done and so it it all came out
in the wash but then as I got older and
stronger he let me do use the tractor
and then I was I was hauling hay bales
and we didn't have we you know I would
help the neighbors sometimes with their
they had square bales but we had the big
round bales those thousand pounds all
those Circle ones I see out the field
bigger than the goddamn John Deer
absolutely so you have to use those you
have a big fork on the front a fork on
the back and you you know uh so you have
to kind of run them through down who the
hell are you giving those who's who's
taking those uh ranchers is that feed
feed for because in the winter there's
not you know all that alala Milo all
that stuff you know you can't get it
anywhere so you have to bail it up in
the summer and then feed your Livestock
in the winter all right right so that's
what it's for so you you we would bail
it up in the summer then we'd stack it
in the barn or out in the field
somewhere and then put a tarp over it or
whatever and then in the winter you know
all the farmers with livestock are just
taking it for feed every day you know
and that's their that's their supply was
this when you would do you say this your
summer job is it close are you commuting
or do you go to Grandma Grandpa stay it
wasn't that close it was about 2 hours
was 2our drive so are you staying for
the summer out there uh I would stay for
weeks at a time so i' like you need to
go down and work on the farm for a
couple weeks okay so two weeks down
there and then I'd come back to Kansas
City and I get to hang out with my
friends and is this mom or dad side mom
mom side Mom and Mom's an only child
okay that's why they're down there
running the farm right now yeah so and
while you had to go do it yeah and I
still go down and help out my dad my dad
yeah my dad he's you know he's in his
today's his birthday as a matter of fact
sh well happy birthday Mr wle and he's
83 and he's out there still
working pasture and working I tell you I
I really do feel like those people that
stayed active whether it was farming or
whatever the [__] it was they're they're
keeping their machine in motion they're
using their muscles in different ways
you know like if you don't work out for
a while and then all of a sudden you
hang a light bulb you're like God damn
my shoulders hurt you hurt yourself you
pull muscles he's out there bailing a
and [__] he's I if I went out there
right now and did what your dad did I
wouldn't be able to wipe my own ass
tomorrow I promise you that I promise
you be a it's 100% true and it's it it
does just come down to keeping your body
you don't have like I I I played Sports
in in school and uh so I'm always think
you know well I got to go get in some
you know weightlifting and some Sprint
workout and I got to get my cardio up I
got give me a break you know you get to
a certain point in your life you're like
what am I I'm not competing in anything
that demands this of I had my ads I had
them so now it's all just about like I
don't even have to do anything other
than just stretch out just stretch out
that's all I need to do is stretch out
but I I I also eat too much [__] ice
cream now I [__] love it I eat it and
I can feel the inflammation I can feel
it my body's just one swollen Beast
everything hurts when I get out of bed
it's all because I [__] I put that
ice cream down I'm Pizza dude I'm I'm
that's that's and we all got it we all
got it but me is sugar man it's that
goddamn ice cream I Can't Get Enough
well you're you know it dude cuz right
now like if some [__] went down and they
were like run I'd tear every my hand I
at 50 I can't just break out into a
Sprint on the spot I said my best friend
and I or one of my best friends uh we
went to uh the Royals baseball fantasy
camp in 16
2016 and they tell you Hey guys you're
not as young as you think you are you
know you know don't everybody's gonna
try to get out there and get some just
go easy all right go easy and we're like
yeah no that makes sense that's good
advice I appreciate that first time I
got a hit I sprinted out of the back box
for first base I pulled both I pulled
both my quads oh yeah both my quads I
think my hammy I don't know just just
and then of course I'm out the field and
people were like people like you okay
I'm like I'm good I'm good I'm so good
heard three pops but someone hits it to
me so I I instantly go from a stand
still to a Sprint I blow out the other
no I was so my legs were yellow you know
when that that deep bruising is yellow I
was yellow legs on the front and the
backs every I pulled everything within a
matter of days my arm I I threw out my
arm I had to like attend the nights I'm
like I gotta have John Tommy John
surgery this was all in a matter of two
or three days Fantasy Camp from a
fantasy baseball camp Royals and then
then on top of that uh they go okay well
we got games today because we play two
games a day one in the morning one in
the afternoon by the time we were you
know and George Brett is my manager of
my team and he's my childhood Idol and
all this stuff so I'm like I got to
perform
all Rota you around positions and stuff
yeah yeah you get to play first base you
get to do all this stuff and and I I
literally was the funniest thing ever
the entire [__] Camp all these old
men you know middle-aged guys we're all
standing in an ice tub it's one big ice
tub we're standing it up to our tits and
we got beers cuz we're like [__] it we
can't do great everybody's got from here
down pink bodies pink bodies and they're
holding beers and they're just kind of
keeping the beer in the it cuz it's so
[__] cold in there and and that's it
everybody was done no one could play we
were all injured with pulled muscles and
stuff so yeah I hear you when I now
nowadays I just need to stretch that's
the only thing and I need to cut down on
the sugar I guess so um you say your
parents now running the farm yeah Dad
too Dad and M are dad and mom are still
together yep and then your grandparents
both gone or they and what was that like
for you cuz how old were you when that
happened um they were within probably
six or seven years of each other passing
so grandmother passed
first um she was a wonderful lady uh you
spent a lot of time with her I did and
she was a historian she was kind of the
Cooper County historian and she really
enjoyed it and turned me on to history
even though I didn't you know at the
time you know teenage boy I want to play
video games I want to you know I don't
know play you know
Samurai yeah you know I'm not interested
in history basically but she would drag
me you know we're going to go to do this
we're going to go do
that and she was very into history and
and she lit a fuse in me somehow some
way it got through my armor and now I
I'm so grateful to her because my
passion for history now comes from her
clearly and and I really appreciate uh
her giving me that and she was a great
laugher she loved good stories uh she
was very willing to laugh at herself
chain smoker chain smoker that woman
smoked this is like in the 70s and ' 80s
too like okay so I remember one spring
break my freshman year uh of high school
I'm a ninth grader right prepubescent on
the verge you know and it was spring
break and and she calls my mom and says
we're going on a road trip you know grab
grab Rob because we you know back then
we didn't spring break we didn't have
plans you know you just had a week off
of school next thing I know I'm in
Grandma's cataly back with my mom you
know not the coolest thing in the world
but we're driving around Kentucky
looking at Old grave sites because she's
trying to get in the Daughters of the
American Revolution or something and you
have to prove that you have a family
member that was in the revolution war
want to be buried right but this was
before the internet this is before the
internet or anything so I was the
internet so basically they'd hand me a
one of those scratch pads you know or
whatever and we would pull up and this
it's freezing it's March you know we'
pull up at a graveyard and she'd go it
should be three rows deep seven rows
over you know and it should be a
headstone look for Ryan o Soo and I oh
Jesus so they kicked me out of the car
and I'd have to go through these
graveyards finding headstones and yeah
etch them you know or whatever and and
come back and go this one they go no
that's not it you know and God damn it
so I'm driving all over Kentucky doing
yeah she's just chain smoking and she
barely cracked the window when she did
it look like sp's van you know just
smoke rolling out of it and [__] and
then then when I got back in the car it
was no mercy it was still just
Relentless chains smoking and weak in
the car with that you know by the time I
got back I had bags under my eyes and
pale so what she having you scratch for
is that she saying that was my relative
there because then she could say okay
this man does exist he is buried in this
place and then because the genealogy
back then was not you know what they
have today you know you had to do the
work you had to go to County Libraries
you had to go dig up obituaries you had
to go back and connect dots on I mean it
was work and she would do it but I was
off in her legs you know on that stuff
uh so anyway uh she passed um um she was
she was 80 so she had a good long life
but especially smoking like that but
yeah she smoked a lot and um then my
grandfather uh he was a World War II vet
um hardworking guy nice funny love to
play cards you know good-natured folk um
and uh
uh he ran the farm you know after Grammy
passed and and then um then uh he passed
probably five or six years later he was
90 something wow yeah so he made it to
his 90s was it just old age that finally
got him or yeah yeah I think it was his
his heart when did he really slow down
though like when did you see he had a he
had a heart attack he had a he had a big
heart attack though he was 87 when he
had the heart attack but up until then
he was still out there getting it done
and everything up until 87 and just you
know still like I'll go I'll work I'll
do this I'll do that you know like I got
it you like let me let me let me do
something you know but uh yeah you know
again I think they came from tougher
stock they just did definitely and so I
talk about it all the time your
grandfather's World War II our fathers
are Vietnam and we're like I want to be
a clown and like what the [__] are you
talking about exactly they're just
different man yeah they're just
different man you couldn't tell me had
to go to dday if I I would have killed
myself I would have killed myself like
never mind I'll just get it done yeah
like I I um I served I served in the
Marines and so I didn't have a problem
with the doing certain things but even
now even now like the other day I
literally just last week I walked in
opened my refrigerator and the light
wasn't on I could tell it wasn't working
I was like ah I was like well it's
broken time to buy a new refrigerator
that's my first thought not what let me
check things let me let me troubleshoot
this because and we have Google and
YouTube to look at they didn't yeah and
so I I was like well the light worked on
when I came in the kitchen so it I don't
think it's the fuse box right but the
yeah so but I was like well I've got to
do something or all this food's going to
spoil you know but I was pouting about
it I was pouting about it I didn't want
to do anything I was like just [__]
work I don't have time for this [__]
you know i' I've got other things to do
whatever that is read something on the
Internet probably but I I had an
epiphany and I was like oh well the let
me see if maybe it's some just this
section and sure enough the coffee maker
wasn't working I was like ah okay so
it's it is so I went out to the fuse
it's just the fuse box I just had to
flip the thing that's it everything went
back to work but I was willing to buy a
new refrigerator is my point you know
like had I been given the option in that
moment I was like yeah buy it I'll buy
it I'll buy it let just just [__] it
rle Jesus
Christ that's but that's they definitely
different man they can build [__] like
build a deck I can't build a deck I can
fish I can do that kind of [__] but I
can't I can fish I can run a trot line
we used to crab all the time I can do
that I used to be able to on my old cars
I would do my oil my brakes my tuneups
all that [__] oh you could really do it
you you're good I can't do it now you
know like I go to my my stepson's big
into the cars and college working on
them and stuff and I'm like they told me
when I leased this [__] car it's got
30 some computers on it he's like yep
and if you [__] anything up you know and
I'm like I don't even know how to do
that well I I I drove I have a Tesla and
and I'm baffled half the time they're
it's a software download problem and I'm
like well [__] fix it because I don't
I can't get in and out of my car I can't
open the passenger door I can't do you
know and I don't know jack [__] about it
and I don't have time this is not what I
signed up to be I'm not I didn't sign up
to do this I'm not I'm not a computer
engineer I'm not a software engineer so
make the car work or [__] off I'm in a
building now where everything's fancy
and the [__] appliances are F nest
and all this [__] the dude came in the
other day this older Mexican dude and
we're talking I said you know what [__]
this he is the the [__] it goes on when
it wants to [__] go on I say you know
what used to work all the time my old
school honey well thermostat I just
flick that little button and I never had
a problem with it never thought about it
ever ever it didn't just come on and go
off when it wanted to
this [__] fridge over here is dinging
nonstop tell me about the freezer the
dishwasher not flashing a red light on
the floor why is there a light on the
floor all my old [__] worked just fine
fine just fine I couldn't agree you know
and I do believe that you know uh for
for a multitude of reasons but men are
losing a lot of man's skills quote man
skills the women are losing a lot of
women's skills I mean you know it's
really hard to find women that that have
traditional feminine skills and it's
hard to find a man who has traditional
masculine skills so it's I'm not
throwing rocks here but it is hard thr
rocks at both sides but yeah but it's
hard it's hard to find it these days um
I consider myself very I have a
girlfriend right now who is an uh she's
amazing cook she's amazing cook she
takes care she can do stuff she she's
not intimidated to repair things and and
and she's get a drill yeah she's got
skills like I'm like okay all right I
feel very why she probably had a dad
like did she did she absolutely did well
and she's from Poland and so her you
know I think she just they don't throw
away stuff over there you know back in
the day and and and her folks grew up in
a lot tougher regime uh than most people
so yeah she's just tougher so let me ask
you this then cuz I want to go back to
this this working early and in the
fields and stuff like that cuz you're a
hell of a hustler you're everywhere do
you feel like that um that work ethic
was instilled in you from that that sort
of Summer work and really just getting
out there and like [__] humping it
like that to make a few bucks yeah I
think so I think there was yes yes I
think there was an expectation that you
would work that's your first sort of job
ever right you're Middle School yeah I
can't imagine doing anything before that
yeah Mo and laws back in K but but yeah
but yes that was there's an expectation
and and there's a lot of pride in your
work you know and a lot of uh you know
my dad when I mowed lawns he was like
you got to bag the you got to bag it up
right I like d they don't even want to
bag you know like you got to bag it up
okay it needs to look nice it needs to
look good if you're going to do it do it
right or don't do it first time right
you don't have to go back you know it's
like that Abraham link quote I I'm a
slow Walker but I never walk backwards
he goes just do your do your work you
know and and you know you get that beat
into enough you and you start doing it
and then when you start owning stuff and
you start then you're like yeah I care
about this you know I remember I was I
was Lu my my dad and my mom bought me my
first car mhm okay what was it uh my
first car was my mom's old car it was a
a 76 Chrysler Newport okay uh big 400
block engine in it seven miles to the
gallon I swear to God cuz it was 76 it
was the first year to have that c power
steer into like if you touched at the
car like all over the there was a some
clog in the fuel line too so when you
push the gas it it would die the engine
would go but if you held it you know
like so you'd push hard because you were
afraid it was going to die it would Roar
to life so go and then you lay rubber
every intersection you're like I'm not
trying to I swear I just want to it's
just going to die high beam clicks on
the floor is it the P yes absolutely
that's I still think the high beam
should be there click click come on
that's a driver's dream um but yeah so
uh so that but but I had a it was a
Sunbird a little p Sun yeah um and I
treated that car like [__] okay because
I didn't it was it was given to me I I
I'm I'm not obnoxiously treated like
[__] but I you know it was very it was
very like whatever whatever whatever you
know I got a door ding I was like it
sucks ownership changes everything it
really does because soon as I got my
first car and I pay I'm making the
payments on it and I'm I mean I used to
I I'm not kidding I used to take it and
wax it every Sunday
I used to you know I
mean I I treated that thing like gold I
would and it because it mattered it's
that changes how you approach things so
worning learning the work ethics
learning that that stuff early a lot of
the lessons you learn early that you
haven't connected the dots on things yet
you just do it because they say to do it
and trust them and you're like all right
fine whatever and you do it but then if
you're lucky you get to a place in your
life where you're like you have these
epiphanies where you're like oh I get it
now I see why it matters I see why this
is important I see why he cared I see
why this I see you know you know if I'm
paying someone to do something and they
do a good job I'm like Ah that's amazing
you did a good job thank you for caring
thank you for investing in in in your
your job and working at it and effort
and and and if you become a boss then
you know you start to appreciate the
work of others and you see you can
separate the wheat from the chaff real
fast you can be like this guy's not
going anywhere this guy's going to be my
boss someday you know and it's real
cleared to see real clear so anyway yes
I I think working down on that farm
early helped get the work ethic in there
and then the Marines obviously helped
too yeah I'll bet what made you decide
to want to go on the Marines always
wanted to serve I just thought I was
very idealistic grandfather was Air
Force uh Army back then it was Army
aircore your D Marine as well no no he
he uh he never he um he never served oh
he didn't no he wanted to he was willing
to let me put that way he was willing to
but every he had the best run of luck
you've ever heard of so when he was
first eligible um uh Kennedy came in and
said Kennedy I'm sorry I'm just hearing
he's Kenedy came in and said if you're
in college your draft is deferred until
you're out of college okay so he was in
college so his his draft got deferred
until after college he got married and
then
uh um Johnson came in and said okay if
you're married and have a job or
whatever your draft is deferred so he
got deferred again and then uh there was
some other there was another thing that
got him is there a cut is there an age
cut off no well yes I think 35 or
something but but you know um anyway he
got these these deferments and by the
time you know they never called him they
just never called him so he was he was
in the his name was go but never got the
call just never got the call so ain't
nothing wrong with that yeah no exactly
so I'm very happy no matter where or how
you're hydrating this season liquid IV
is the hydration brand fueling your
well-being and their hydration
multiplier can keep you going through
the end of the year and Beyond it's got
three times the electrolytes of the
leading sports drink plus eight vitamins
and nutrients all in a single stick now
it's available and sugar-free you can
choose from three delicious flavors
white peach green grape and lemon lime
which is my favorite uh I tell you I
love liquid IV you guys know they've
been a sponsor for a long time here at
the do we love them we give them out to
every guest that comes in they they're
so generous with their supplies man we
have them here at the studio we take
them on the road we give them out to
guest everybody loves liquid IV and one
stick of liquid IV and 16 ounces of
water hydrates better than water alone
with three times the electrolytes of the
leading sports drink no artificial
sweeteners and zero sugar plus contains
eight vitamins and nutrients for
everyday Wellness grab your liquid IV
hydration multiplier sugar-free in bulk
nationwide at Costco or you can get 20%
off when you go to liquid i.com and use
code honey do a checkout that's 20% off
of anything you order when you shop
better hydration today using promo code
honeydew at liquid i.com now let's get
back to the de so what made you always
want to sered then was it your
grandfather's influence or maybe there
was something there um uh there's a lot
of military in my family going way back
so uh there's I always had affinity for
that I was very idealistic I really
believed uh and I still do in America uh
um uh Kennedy's you know what can you do
for your country don't ask what they can
do for you what can you do for them I
liked that I believed in that I thought
the best way I could serve this country
was through military service so that's
what I did
and and so it wasn't this thing like I'm
in Kansas there's no other option for me
or no no listen I was in college I had
you know were in college where did you
go Kansas University oh you're a jhawk
I'm a jha all right bro yeah um so you
were in college and left or did you
graduate and then go I I graduated well
I I signed up when I was an undergrad I
signed up when I was 19 okay went
through the officer candidate program
and when I graduated I took my
commission and I had my pilot's license
at the time so how' you get a pilot's
license my grandfather cuz he he was the
Army aircore he was like did he have
like a little cess or something at the
no he just he just wanted he wanted to
be a pilot when he was in the Army but
he was I think he was too short so he
couldn't get uh his his or they do
measurements in the cockpit you know his
legs were too short or something was too
short his torso or something so he
didn't get to fly when he was in the
Army aircore he was Intelligence officer
so he he um or intelligence Sergeant but
anyway he was doing other stuff but he
always wanted to fly so he was like like
listen if you want to get your pilot
license I'll pay for it so I was like
yeah so I did and then I got a flight
contract with the Marines so so you flew
for the Marines I started flying for the
Marines what what were you flying uh
just t-34s uh what's I'm ignant a
training it's a training plane but are
we talking about Jets or is this like a
cargo plane it's a it's a it's a single
engine trainer single engine single
engine trainer um and uh flew down in
Corpus Christie um you know and I I I
had like I said I had my pilot's license
while I was an undergrad so I used to
fly Cessnas Pipers you know all kinds of
different like 19 and 20 years old
you're flying that [__] yeah and you're
not you weren't that didn't scare you
you ever have any close calls no I
didn't have any close calls I had scary
moments uh uh like I was on a cross
country one time and you flew it across
country well but it when I call it AC
cross country in aviation terms is 50
miles or more okay okay so so I was
flying from Lawrence Kansas down to
Springfield Missouri and when you just
land in an airport there and then come
back yeah okay and then you get cross
country time that's your training right
but I was doing a solo cross country and
that's usually a three- leg trip so I
flew from Lawrence Kansas to Columbia
Missouri down to Springfield Missouri
and then back to Lawrence Kansas and are
you constant communication this whole
time is someone always there no no
you're on your own and you're talking to
towers and you're talking to airports
but when you get in reach yeah so if
some [__] goes down in between then they
just we haven't heard from Robin you got
to deal with it okay so but I remember
and and back then you know now they have
all these wonderful uh navigations and
and uh yeah I feel like now a GPS on
your probably an app on your [__] abely
your phone can get you anywhere you need
to go and and the avionics they have now
are phenomenal well back then it was old
school you know animated you know you
had your six-pack of you know air speed
fuel uh you know Horizon all that stuff
but it was there you didn't have what
you have today so you had a a big map
literally an old paper map that you
would unfold and You' have drawn your
lines and get estimated your fuel and
done all this figured out all the the
comms and all that stuff beforeand and
as I was flying from Springfield to back
to Lawrence or vice ver Columbia down to
Springfield um I'm like because it's
visual flight rules VFR so I'm I'm
sitting there looking going okay the
there's that City because when you're up
about 5,000 ft you can say okay there's
a city there's a city there's the
highway there's a gravel pit okay I know
exactly where I'm at I'm right where I
should be but I got up there and I was
like that not that's not that there's
not I couldn't find where I was and I
was lost and I'm flying and it's a very
scary feeling because you're like
nothing is where it should be um and
you're burning fuel and you're just
flying somewhere yeah somewhere yeah and
you're like this is not good you you
need to get your bearings quickly and
you're just by yourself you know and are
you over fields out there or you're over
cities Fields hot roads you know you're
just taking it Taking It to the streets
and
and the good thing it's it's but I liked
it it was there was resilience and it
lessons and resilience because no one's
going to solve that problem but you the
plane's not going to land itself no
one's going to find where you are you
know you've got to solve these problems
and so you just have to calm down get
your breath keep the plane straight and
level and start working the problem and
and you start going okay where am I what
what do I see why do I okay I see this
city off here I just flew over a a you
know a gravel pit big industrial grav a
pit that's that's something like that's
on the map so let's start just and you
start working the problem and then I
found myself and of course I was a
little off whatever and corrected for it
landed safely everything's good but but
those are are uh resilient lessons or
whatever you know all right so I want to
shift gears to something now because you
seem like you had a hell of a wonderful
time growing up no complaints yeah no
complaints I mean you don't have
any uh any unfortunate early death from
Patriarchs or matriarchs you don't seem
like it got wild so you had a solid
upbringing of your sounds like
Grandparents were together till
literally death to us part your mom and
dad are still together how long they've
been married now uh this was 60 years
okay so what age do you become a
father and did you always want to be a
dad yeah you did yeah I did I I I I
wanted to be a father and I I became one
in the the spring of '
04 um to my daughter uh who is uh she's
in college right now studying to be
she's a theater major and uh she's very
talented I will say that so I I I cringe
sometimes when I think
about uh my kids going to a life in the
Arts because it's it's tough It's a
tough it's a tough rad my daughter's
nine and I tell her now like I will
support anything you want to do but if
you could do anything other than this
[__] do it there's no structure there's
no rhyme there's no reason somebody can
look at you and go you remind me of an
ant that I [__] hated yeah pass ex
nothing to do with anything else there
there's so much subjectivity yes to it
so much so much now you often by people
near as qualified as you or as good as
you or anything anything a lot of
failed this is now booking this or you
know what I mean like oh now you're a
gate keeper all of a sudden yeah exactly
exactly it's so so life in the Arts can
be hard and there's no way around that
it is hard the good thing though I will
say this though I do I do in my heart of
hearts believe that Talent can't be
denied not forever agree they can hold
you down for 20 or 30 years they can
keep they can hold you down for a while
they can they can hold you down for a
while or keep you out of things for a
while or you may miss an opportunity or
you know something doesn't connect or
for whatever reason the Stars don't
align but eventually if you've got the
talent and you got the drive you're
going to get your shot that's the other
part it's the drive you got to have that
hustle you got to have there's a lot of
talented people out there right now that
have no [__] hustle and they could be
gazillionaires and they're just sitting
there bitching and boohoo with all the
[__] more talented than you and I
combined yeah it's true it's it's a
Tailor's oldest time and that's where I
was getting at with you sitting in these
fields all day long just chopping bushes
it [__] builds a uh you know it
builds a hustle it builds a drive it
builds a motivate you're going to find
out real quick your grandfather came
back was like nope you're done but he
didn't he didn't cuz you worked yeah so
you're a married man at the time this is
what I wanted to ask you about because
you come from no divorce yeah none of
that and then you get divorced yeah so I
mean I was engaged we we didn't even get
to the marriage so I want to know from
your point of view like as a dad like
how did that mess with you and did it
did you were you able to talk to your
father as a resource to go through
something even though he had never had
to you know so what was that like for
you well the you know it's It's tricky
because the the this is this is really
unfortunate but the divorce is still
going on this has been it's been going
on for three years it's um it's so it's
really painful and it's really ugly and
it it doesn't have to be it shouldn't
never be but it is and there's nothing I
can do about it and I can't even really
talk about it because um I respect that
yes because there's still all this legal
action that's got got to take place but
it broke my heart it just shattered it
it really did and uh um and I don't talk
about it very much um and be because I
do I you know I feel like I failed you
know I I we were Mar as what a husband
or a father no no not you know I I have
they're separate the by the way the
divorce was a good thing okay it was a
really good thing the right thing it was
the right thing that's probably a good
way to say it it was the right thing
doesn't make it any less painful doesn't
make it any less hurtful doesn't make
you know and especially the stuff now
has become so hurtful and so unnecessary
but um yeah I is not the life I
envisioned I had a vision in my mind of
what my life was going to be and it and
it did not turn out that way and so you
have to it takes a lot to
recalibrate um what your dreams are what
your hes are uh what you want for your
kids you know all that stuff how to
shift gears now to being a single parent
and yeah and it and it's can we stay
close in proximity and all that I want
to be around them I want to see them I
want to be a dad not a [__] play a
play a pal yeah and we have 50/50
custody you know and and so um so we
make that work um but um anyway there's
just a lot of a lot of stuff but so how
was your very frustrating and my dad was
great my dad was amazing you know that's
the thing you know you you take your
parents for granted so easily because
you think they don't know and we also
think this is a generation again we're
talking about these old school walk it
off [__] what would he know
about
heartache you know what a stupid thing
to think you know what would he think
you know he doesn't know what I'm going
through well he might he might not know
what I'm personally going through right
because he hasn't been in that situation
of divorce or what you know all the
things that came on with that
but he he knows me and he knows the
human condition he knows betrayal he
knows hurt he knows he has a wealth of
Lifetime experience and more importantly
he wasn't there to to lecture or to you
know pump me up with advice or whatever
he he knows I'm pretty Savvy guy he
knows I'm pretty I have pretty good
emotional intelligence pretty good
nobody's perfect but pretty good and so
he just was a great resource a great
listener and offered really you know uh
good advice good Sound Advice uh that
that resonated with me and made me
realize yeah you know what I've been
looking at this wrong I've been thinking
about this with the wrong mindset and so
to have that guidance from somebody that
you really admire and really care about
and
value their
opinion man that's invaluable and it's
that thing where
you
know God forbid my kids you know I I
don't want them to have hard times but
there's it's inevitable right and and
you can't protect me I now I want them
to be resilient when the hard times come
that's right cuz they're coming they're
coming yeah I got through most of my
life pretty good but but I got walloped
yeah what I want to ask you this cuz a
lot of people get walloped early what
year did it really age I mean did it
start hitting for you my my beating
started at 50 no yeah for real dude you
got
well no but some people don't even live
that long I know but now now we're
talking about what I would consider you
know the the the thing that's most hurt
me the most that's hurt me the most now
I've been I've been to war I've been to
you know I've done other things are that
are are trying right but nothing broke
my heart nothing broke my heart like
this did okay this was a heartbreaker
what was the hardest part about this I
know you're still in it but when it
happened was the hardest part for
you just and I can't drill down on too
much of this because I don't want to say
too many things uh just about just the
Betrayal the the the the the what about
not getting to see your kids every day
now now now they're yes cuz let me ask
you let me ask you questions instead of
asking you this CU I'm going to be
respectful here yeah I would do a lot of
future tripping I my daughter lives two
miles away with her mom when she's with
her mom but to me it's [__] Mars mhm
it might as well be Mars over there
there's a whole another world going on
over there things going on that I don't
know about I it comes back to me through
my daughter or whatever it is and that
was also like all right well here's this
kid so it happened for me young she was
one here's this kid now that I lose half
her [__] life just statistically if
we're 50/50 that's [__] gone yeah and
then the other half the time what the
hell's going on over there that nobody
wants to tell me about and what's
happening so I would find myself like
freaking out about any dude she'd want
to bring in and you know she's got a
good boyfriend now I'll be honest he he
gets the job his job was to take care of
her my daughter's got a dad a dad you do
what you need to do over there and I
also know that when I start getting [__]
at me homeboy's not doing his job over
there like you need to step it up for
all of us right now bro okay I got the
dad [__] you take well some of that
stuff was just repugnant yeah to me the
thought of the thought of another man
uh taking my da fish engaging with my
child you know on that level you know it
was
repugnant you know I guess I've had to
grow up because it's reality you know
and that's that's what we're talking
about life don't give a [__] what you
want exactly I saw uh my daughter's
mother had a boyfriend and I saw my my
daughter was young and she went up and
she hugged his leg and it I went it
crushed me yeah it crushed me but then I
had to be a man about it and say well
you know what my daughter's not scared
of that man he must be kind to her he
must be treating her in a way where it's
a good mindset it's a hard mind and then
I cry again you know what I mean like
yeah but that's a good mindset that's a
that's a that's a good way that's a good
way to look at it that's a really good
way because you could torture yourself
torture yourself and did you did you
beat yourself up for a in the beginning
in the beginning I was just so hurt by
all of it I was just so CU I was uh you
know was a little caught off guard by
things and you know so I was I was hurt
I was really really hurt by all of it um
so and then you know um just upset by
and then there were some you know other
Antics that you know just there's all
these things you know and everybody's
got a story everybody's got a story I
got it I got it so the thing the thing
bothers me though you know is it not you
know boy I I I I could go off but I I
can't at the same time so I need
to it's just so frustrating none of this
has to none of where I'm at now is not
necessary all of it I know all of it so
let me ask you this then how are you
being a good dad now how are you still
trying to work through this and and be
the dad now that you need to be because
now you can't be everyday dad and over
there all the time under the same roof
and yeah I think I think just trying you
know uh uh you have to be so careful
because part of you is like I'm gonna
I'm GNA you know I'm G to Dazzle I'm
going to you know I'm going to make it
the best times ever we're going to go do
amazing things and you know you it's
you're flailing at that point and that's
not we can't be doing
Disneyland and it's not true to yourself
it's not true and and you know the kids
eventually they may like some of the
perks of you freaking out but eventually
you know that's not what they need no
you know and if you're if you care about
them then you have to give them tools to
win in
life which you know is a struggle
because the teenagers go through some
very weird withdrawals you know and and
I remember being a
a pubescent teenage boy you know I I
withdrew you know you kind of go into
your cave to kind of figure out what's
going on and what's happening to you and
why this is happening and where you fit
in the world and what's your Niche and
what are you good at and and it happens
to boys and girls I think it it happens
in different ways because now it's kind
of fun my my daughter's in college she's
she's 19 she'll be 20 this year but she
um what I enjoy seeing is I remember her
in high school you know very withdrawn
very almost a Fu Vibe it wasn't she was
always gracious and nice but it was very
much I don't have time I don't have time
and now she wants to make time now we're
connecting now she's like coming back a
little bit and now the boy's going
through his withdrawal which I think is
natural that's I think it's age
appropriate I think it's natural but
when you're in a divorce situation you
always panic and think something's wrong
something's double wrong I got to I got
to I got to jump in here and do
something yeah and you can't you don't
have a partner even talk
to with it like hey what are you seeing
what are you thinking yeah so so that
that part blows because you know so all
I can do is what I think I've tried to
do my whole life which is set the
example and that's it try to be gracious
be fun be happy if he's screwing up call
him out on it you know don't let him get
away with [__] you still got chores to
do this isn't a cakewalk you know you
got and get off your ass and let's go do
something cuz you're going to sit here
and play on your phone all day it's
Saturday you know let's go um tomorrow
while I'm watching football yeah well
and by the way like
Sunday I'll tell my daughter take your
tablet do whatever you want well we I
always say we'll watch football I'm
right he's on his phone doing playing
video games whatever but but uh all you
can do is just try to do that and then
and when I say set the example I mean
show them show them how you how you
interact with people uh like I said I'm
I'm have a girlfriend I'm dating now
she's a wonderful lady wonderful lady so
I I want him to see you know what a
hopefully a healthy thing looks like
agreed like they should see what you
know love looks like their dag gets to
love this lady this lady's nice to their
father that feels good in here that
looks good ex and so that's the best you
can do I think you know and and uh and
you just have to trust that not not
everything is as fragile as you think it
is not everything you can't worry about
everything all the time I hear from most
people the number one regret they have
at the end of their life is they worry
too much you know I always he do you
have any advice for somebody over there
I ask these octogenarians and all these
and they was like yeah don't worry so
much just relax you know live your
life and so yeah I just want the best
for the kids and if I can help them be
resilient when they face troubles
because they're they're going to get hit
we're all we you don't get out of this
thing hit you till 50 think about that
nobody gets out alive and no one gets
out without any scars so I consider
myself lucky that the scars that I got
didn't come till the ones that really
hurt me didn't come till late I had I
mean I broke up with girls and they
broke up with me and I got fired from
jobs and I you know there's there's
things that sucked right sucked there's
difference than devastating than things
that really take your breath away and
things that break your heart tell me
about this then because this is a solo
thing that you could talk about your
lowest at that point where were
you well it seemed like the the whole
world turned into a [__] show CU this
all happened at the beginning of Co oh
yeah three years that's right 202 so it
it all start that's all going on and the
world the world's upside down people
wearing mask everybody's angry at each
other you know you know I was in a
confused State uh almost like did you go
get your own place oh yeah tell me about
the first night you spent in that
place yeah
sad
night hard yeah
um the the reality you know I think
there's a there's a level of denial
maybe where in the back of your mind you
you know it started as a
separation um and then I see and then it
turned into you know uh other things did
you was your were there at least hopes
that you think you hoping you could make
it work out from the separation
standpoint first okay yes of course so
your mindset is all right this is
temporary we'll try to work this yes of
course and then and then there's a level
of boy some other things happened in
there that led me to believe that was
the case MH and in fact it was quite the
opposite okay so I was I so then there's
a new realization it possible to say
double
devastating it it was a it was a double
whammy okay okay and so yeah it was so
now you're dealing with a whole new
thing right there yeah now you know
you're there this is it yeah and you
know and then there's the there there's
always the reflection like you
know you always reflect I think you
should anyway you know what did I do
right what did I do wrong how could I
have done it different oh you know you
think about the good times but then you
know you start to work your way through
it you you have family and friends thank
God uh therapist you know that was big
help getting your head right and then
realiz who was your biggest help who was
your biggest Ally my dad was had a
feeling you were going to say my dad my
dad really just interesting for a man
that again you don't think he's from the
feelings generation and also never went
through this either you know and he he
amazed me with his emotional
intelligence he amazed me with
his understanding of you know some of
the intimate details of what was going
on and you know just no judgment never
judged any of it um but was open to
hearing all of it um because I didn't
pull any punches with him you know I
said look here's here's everything and
you know that's scary yeah hell yeah it
is to admit that yeah and and yet he
took it all in processed it and then
gave me his honest assessment on where
things were and what he thought of
situation and and and that perspective I
value so much so I was I I'm forever
grateful yeah um cuz he really delivered
at a time when I needed him to see my
dad died when he was 42 I was 16 I wish
I had this I'm sitting here listening to
you thinking like God I wish I could
have had my dad to talk to when this
happened cuz he went through this he did
go through this and I would have been
like what was that like for you you know
my mom's cheating on him there's no text
he's an hour away at at National Airport
working for PanAm he can't you know what
I mean anyway I'm sitting here listening
to that what about your mom was your mom
someone that was a little more reserved
on this or yeah well my mom's an old
German school teacher you know she's
she's she's tough but very loving and
very gracious so I'm not picking on mom
she's great but Dad was the guy but and
and yeah and she was a great listener
too but but Dad was
the that was the voice I needed to hear
you know I needed to I needed to hear
from a uh a masculine energy I guess and
and then and my girlfriend she was she
was really nice and really supportive
and really understood what was happening
could see it for what it was um and was
patient still is because it's still
going on yeah and and still very patient
with uh you know some ugliness um so so
I I was and my sister was fantastic my
sister is amazing yeah are they as good
um uh grandfathers and Grandmom's and
ants as they are Dads Moms and sisters
they're amazing people I I feel so lucky
and then and even my my my best friends
back in Kansas City or my Marine buddies
or you know anybody that was is is in my
you know Inner Circle uh uh that I
reached out and talked to or deal you
know brought it up because yeah also I
don't want to dump my problems on people
um and nobody cares no you know that
sounds harsh or whatever but at the end
of the day everyone's got their [__]
everybody's got their [__] right their
own [__] and but I want to be there for
my friends you know when they're hurting
I want to listen what what are they what
do you need you need me to listen you
want want advice you want me you want me
to shut up you want me to you know you
want to drink beers what are we going to
do what are we doing here I want to be
that for them as well and they were that
for me and I got great great advice from
some really great people so I feel
blessed in that in that sense too so
after going through or even still going
through a horrible heartbreak like this
how um how was it trying to get back out
there and meet new people you obviously
met someone but what was that like to be
vulnerable again to open yourself up
again yeah you know honestly I uh um I
met my girlfriend very quickly um it it
didn't take long I I we met and uh kind
of hit it off right away and then um I
don't be honest with you I don't even
know if I was ready for it at all in the
beginning um I think I was still in a
State of Shock about everything and so
you know the first part of our
relationship and I hope this doesn't
hurt her feelings or whatever but you
know I might not have been fully there
present yeah you know not that I not
that I didn't enjoy our time or wasn't
didn't care or I did but I was there
cyone going on up there yes exactly and
and now I I really have an appreciation
for her and uh a deep love and and and
gratitude for her because she is so
amazing
and A Renewed faith maybe cautiously
this is leading to my next question yeah
cuz you know when you stick your f in
the socket sticking it back in the
socket again is can be very
scary so it's like um but I I I I'm
hoping that I you know it it does feel
right you know so so are you as my
question was going to be are you open to
the idea of possibly remarrying again
I'm open to it I'm open to you're not
like no not doing that again I have been
you know over the last couple years I've
been maybe a little down on love down
on
I would say so you know a little little
jaded little you know you know I hear a
tale of Love Gone Wrong and of course
you know I'm like you godamn well no
[__] you know of course that's gonna
happen [__] lying you know I start
going off right and then I got to reel
it back in and I got to remember that's
not everybody that's not every story
that's that's not everybody that's not
parents your grandparents you have
family to look at right there own life
and people one at a time you know and
just uh one day one
person and and let things live or die on
their own Merit not the baggage you
bring to it not the other stuff so yes I
I have not uh quit on happiness or love
or companionship or any of that what
would you do differently in this
marriage boy that's a good question um
I would not uh put my head in the sand I
would deal with issues that need to be
dealt with when they need to be dealt
with and I would not be afraid of the
outcome that's a great [__] answer
yeah a lot of us just put our head down
I put my head in the sand and I was I
was afraid of the outcome let the [__]
stack up and then and then here it comes
I would not do that again and I will not
do that again and are your kid I don't
want to bring your kids but are they
comfortable with you dating and how did
they take that like dad's back out there
again a little older I guess yeah they
they've been really good about it um uh
and they you know they see both their
parents dating um and uh so so I think
it's just something that they dealing
with you know and and I'm sure they
didn't they didn't want to see the
family end either you know it's the
death of a dream I didn't want to see it
end they I'm sure they didn't want to
see it nobody you know so that's painful
and that takes takes time to recalibrate
your feelings your emotions to even
understand them and when you're young
and you don't know you don't have any
frame of reference really of what
heartache feels like what pain feels
like what is what is this you know it's
it takes time because they don't even
they don't have a frame of reference no
you know when it happened to me at 50 I
had all kinds of examples and friends
and I've had disappointments and I've
had heartbreak also you're 50 so your
life experience your knowledge your they
know nothing I could I had trouble
processing right ex that's what I'm
saying if I'm having trouble processing
a yeah then then to put that onto a
child's plate you
know it can be very confusing and
challenging obviously I'm a kid of a
child of divorce and I remember it
happened fifth grade and I
remember um obviously the way I felt was
devastated but my daughter it happened
to her at one she didn't even [__]
remember and I think about that think
about hearing your kids's age now I'm
thinking about me and her is it better
to happen then early and you and you you
live that way knowing you Mom and Dad
are this or is it better to at least
experience Mom and Dad loving each other
for a little while and then all of a
sudden the ax drops I'm not sure I don't
I don't know the answer I don't either I
kind of think it might be getting it out
way early yeah yeah where they don't
have any right picture in their mind
right and Mom and Dad are cool with each
other enough we're professional we get
along enough to go to the game you know
we do all the right thing we're 5050 she
covers I cover we switch we're good on
it we're good on it it listen to me it
took a minute it didn't happen right
away bro it took a minute but cuz I can
tell you that first three years was hot
but uh we got there we're there now and
we don't bat a thousand you know but I'd
say honest to God we're s and a half out
of 10 and that [__] bad a it's a
dream that ain't bad I didn't know we'd
ever get there but maybe eight sometimes
you know we and then for parties
birthday parties and [__] like my car
just got broken into and they stole my
daughter's it's nonsense but they stole
her whole soccer bag with her ball or
cleat but it sucks cuz I got to buy it
all again you know what I'm saying so
she's crying cuz she feels violated I'm
like don't even worry about it you're
getting all new [__] but I can call her
mom be like hey this happened please
take I'll pay for it just take her and
get the stuff cuz she needs it for this
weekend so they went and did all that
already so you know we're there we're
there but it was it didn't start that
way sure and I yeah that's uh yeah
that's fantastic I I well I wish you the
best yeah I uh I genuinely appreciate
you coming on here and opening up about
this stuff I I you know I can't drill
down obviously for a lot of reasons and
so I appreciate you understanding that
but uh yeah yeah and uh well you I
appreciate you inviting me here yeah
thank you for doing this yeah um I told
you before we recorded that I asked
guest their first time here advice you'd
give to your 16-year-old self so I'm
curious what actually you would uh say
to 16-year-old Rob rigle wow cuz you
don't have [__] at the fan for some time
bro I know
it's I say uh what we talked about I
think I would say what we've talked
about I would
um I don't think I could give one piece
of advice I'd have to give a one pager
with a bunch of bullet points on it but
I would say don't worry so much don't
sweat the small stuff and it's all small
stuff right you've heard that so I would
say don't don't let that happen okay
relax have fun chill look on the bright
side get your mindset right and then I
would say when there are
problems they do not get better with
time deal with them in in the moment
deal with them in the
moment and and if it if it's you know if
it's catastrophic so be it let it be and
then and then rebuild but deal with that
deal with it don't put your [__] head
in the sand that's great advice because
we all do it we all do it we all do it
and it's human nature to seek the path
of least resistance that's human nature
but it will it will back up on you in
ways you can't imagine imine and it will
lead to tremendous pain for everybody
involved so just do the painful quick
when it needs to be dealt with don't
wait I would pound that into my head
other than that I'd say rock on man
that's great advice dude it's great
that's great no one's ever come on and
said that um please plug promote
everything one more time yeah wriggles
pick uh you can find it uh I think we're
going to be on all the socials you know
Facebook Twitter uh or Twitter X I guess
it's called now these kids I still call
the Chargers San Diego Chargers I still
can't get used I'll never call come on
give me a break um uh yeah and and you
can find me on social Rob rle um the
name of the show is wriggles pick it's
going to be you know a lot of fun just
interviews and and conversation and and
uh uh it'll be a great way to spend the
morning well thank you dude thank you
very much for being here as always Ryan
Sor and all your social social media
ransler we'll talk to you'all next
[Music]
[Applause]
week